justement à paris des maisons de stars
c'est assez hallucinant je sais pas si
vous le savez mais on peut dormir dans
le lit de madonna c'est possible vous
pouvez également voilà louer les maisons
de stars pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
donc regarder tout moment sur ce sujet
voilà c'est à louer grande maison et
nakiele les vents y en a qui les lourds
dormir dedans bref regardez le sujet sur
les vidéos les maisons de stars et puis
derrière je dis qu'on a plein plein
plein d'anecdotes notamment guillaume
qu'on a filmé beaucoup cas les anecdotes
sur la maison et sur les stars regarder
non ceci n'est pas une auberge de
jeunesse c'est l'appartement de madonna
celui qu'elle partageait avec guy
ritchie à londres et qu'elle loue pour
la modique somme de 8 137 euros la nuit
avec une déco ben standard donc si vous
avez beaucoup beaucoup d'argent vous
pouvez plutôt choisir de vous acheter
une maison de star sur le marché il y en
a plein par exemple le magnifique
penthouse de demi moore à 66 millions
d'euros
immense salon lumineux tout en moquette
trois étages de bois de baies vitrées de
bois de baies vitrées et cerise sur le
gâteau vue imprenable sur central park à
vendre aussi la propriété de johnny depp
et de vanessa paradis dans le sud de la
france un truc de fou avec vignes bars
restaurants privés chapelle au fond du
jardin
deux piscines et même une roulotte le
prix 35 millions d'euros
et si vous avez 12 millions de plus vous
pouvez aussi avoir le penthouse de
johnny depp à los angeles profitez-en il
n'a pas trouvé preneur pour l'instant
parce que la vérité c'est que les
maisons de stars sont tellement dingue
et qu'elles sont presque invendables
céline dion a mis quatre ans à se
débarrasser de son palace de miami plage
privée deux toboggans salle de jeux
simulateur de golf et même des fauteuils
pieds dans l'eau vingt-deux mille mètres
carrés qu'elle a fini par brad est à 50%
mais au final acheter une maison de star
ça vous fait rêver
c'est magnifique ça va être vraiment
rêver là là on va être honnête c'est un
autre monde on peut travailler toute
notre vie voilà ça ce sont des gens qui
ont une vie qu'on aura qu'on n'aura
jamais on parle de millions et de
millions
sébastien ces maisons vous vous les avez
souvent vu j'imagine photographier c'est
intéressant ça pour un paparazzi oui
alors surtout aux états unis mais c'est
vrai que nous le jeu c'était de se
mettre d'eux
de deux mèches avec les les agents
immobiliers à los angeles avoir les bons
et dès qu'il y avait une maison qui
était prête à être achetés on prenait un
hélicoptère a comme on voit sur les
images c'est votre image à vous ça ouais
et donc le but c'était de faire les
premières photos de la maison et ont
récupéré aussi les photos de l'intérieur
parce que quand elles sont en agence
photos de l'auteur
donc on récupère les photos de
l'intérieur on fait des photos en hélico
et la plus belle que vous ayez vu vous
c'est qui celle de qui je vois que c'est
la maison d'arrou spelling quand même le
fameux producteur de gigantesques salles
des beckham au jour doit pas un instant
donc à trèbes c'est quoi cette des
beckham c'est celle là celle d'aaron
spelling aaron spelling qui là qu'il a
fait ça a été sa fille est aujourd'hui
c'est les beckham qui l'est c'est la
plus grande maison des états unis j'y
suis allée elle fait je crois qu'ils
sentent 127 pièce si c'est la première
veillée csn à laruscade en regardant la
top 5 des maisons voilà la maison de
celle de céline dion 61 millions de
dollars mais ça fait 2 repart donc 61
millions d'euros c'est quand même
hallucinant
voilà bien deux c'est djezzy 78 gianni
versace ça c'est à malibu non sylvia me
l'apprendre miami perdra quelque 85
millions d'euros
bill gates 127 et victoria david beckham
dont vous parliez 180 millions d'euros
qu'est-ce qui est parti donc celle là
maintenant c'est gigantea lors c'est
horrible je suis allé dans ses origines
énorme arbre à la télé tu en marbre les
canapés ça c'est horrible c'était les
dents à quelle occasion pour un tournage
de tourner avec lync et le producteur ah
oui le producteur pardon de l'a22 des
corps des blessés là particulier
fascinant c'est que déjà vous arriver il
ya un parking pour 100 voitures
vous vous demandez pourquoi on a 100
voitures et et il ya je crois que 20
chambres et 30 salle de bain il ya
toujours plus de salles de bains là
parce que systématiquement dans les
toilettes on peut boire se repoudrer
regardez regardez le plus c'est quand
même beau non mais vous vous êtes
vulgaire dans votre salon
je connais bien bling non mais c'est
bling des communes était un tennis c'est
tout le match je crois qu'il ya sept
terrains de tennis ya ce qui m'avait
étonné aussi il ya un coffre fort de qui
fait je crois 30 mètres carrés à
l'intérieur mais c'est quoi l'intérêt de
jouer à 14 heures
là je sais pas parce qu'en fait c'est ça
servi pour aaron spelling justement pour
des opérations de promotion et de
marketing il recevait beaucoup d'accords
il a la qualité des grandes fêtes et il
voulait pouvoir montrer je suis l'homme
le plus puissant des limites parce que
j'ai la maison la formule importante de
l'ue catherine et des infos sur les
maisons vous oui parce que c'est
intéressant cette histoire de madonna
qui loue sa maison parce qu'on fait
c'est un business extrêmement mais qu'au
lieu des stars ça met beaucoup star le
fond même de feu johnny hallyday le
faisait sa maison de saint barth été
louée 5000 $ la nuit je crois donc ça
fait petit 35000 euros la semaine quand
même est ce qu'on sait pas c'est qu'à
peine star américaine des françaises
qu'ils font vous serez shine dirty
l'héroïne de charme sur jennifer aniston
même patrice dams et louent leur maison
de malibu et bien qu'ils ont besoin
d'argent même car le très jeune a besoin
d'argent de raison peut-être d'avoir
services et soins des maisons et leurs
piètres grande que cela coûte beaucoup
d'entretien l'entretenir de personnel à
savoir coûte beaucoup d'argent
souvent ils en ont plusieurs résidants
pas tout le temps ils veulent pas la
vendre qui sont âgés donc qu'ils louent
et puis les stars deuxièmement nous ce
qu'on sait pas à part 15 superstar dans
le monde
ils ont des revenus comme ça même s'ils
gagnent beaucoup d'argent bien sûr
revenu sont irréguliers et loué une
maison mais ça laisse la garantie
d'avoir un revenu régulier et dans le
luberon où j'ai la mienne et moi je la
loupe à aider apple cela qui vu leur
maison
mon dieu comment nous placer ça
discrètement par louis mathieu non j'ai
surtout une manière de pas se faire
cambrioler quoi vous qui quand il ya
quelqu'un dans la maison où on voit pas
vouloir arrêter quoi oui il ya un moment
il ya un truc où il va travailler et
c'est juste un mot sur la maison de
céline dion est ce qu il paraît que les
stars parfois pour contrer des maisons
et villas chez du musée bas dir centre
est comme son 300 millions de dollars
derrière de travaux et des toboggans et
tout bas ça donne des maisons à vendre à
400 à 500 millions de dollars
c'est un van damme et que ces unions a
perdu de l'argent oui puisqu'il ignorait
y avait autre chose c'est que les
personnes de miami était outré sur la
surconsommation d'eau douce qui avait
dans cette maison là dedans qu'elle
n'était pas écologique parce que j'ai vu
des toboggans par céline dion n'est pas
écolo donc en fait
quel pompey tout le 12 de ce quartier
deuxième et du coup ça il y avait une
mauvaise publicité sur les sur twitter
les fans vous insulte un mot de magali
store avant continue
il ya souvent si les gens et l'entourage
qui profite de ça parce que
l'appartement de madonna là vous avez
montré c'est pas elle qui le loue ans et
un propriétaire nouveau elle ça fait
quinze ans qu'elle a pas mis un pied là
dedans y loue sa 800 euros la nuit et
moi j'ai regardé dans le même quartier
c'est 200 euros la nuit celle qui se
prend 8 600 euros de plus
juste parce que madonna avec une dent il
ya 15 c'est malin ça c'est vrai à la
merci beaucoup au magal et j